and ritalin is speed which is awesome so
we crush up the ritalin real quick we're
snorting ritalin and eating mushrooms
and then we decide you know what let's
just steal the car let's steal the car
welcome is not happening I'm Ari Shaffir
and tonight the topic is bloodline you
wrote his own book you guys are
absolutely loving please give it up for
mr. Moshe kasher you guys I did write a
book I did write a book cuz I had a I
had a wayward childhood I had a
problematic childhood and I wrote a book
about it a childhood memoir of my
problems growing up it's good my name's
Moshe kasher it's called Catcher in the
Rye and some people laughing because
there's a similarly titled book is that
right
catch catch her in the rise at the what
yeah yeah it's a weird coincidence I
found out about it after I wrote my book
I checked it out I read The Catcher in
the Rye not impressed mine's a
banger so check it out it's a real good
one but it is about the problems that I
had growing up I had problems growing up
and this is a story about some of those
problems there's some contextual
information that you need to know in
order to understand where this story
goes first of all I have two deaf
parents both my parents are deaf the
super in hip-hop both of them it's true
I uh I'm from Oakland California that's
where I'm from
I like making that little gunshot noise
but like due to the effects of
gentrification it's making decreasing
sense every time I do it now it's more
like I'm from Oakland y'all latte
so I'm Oakland California kid two deaf
parents raised on welfare getting into
so much trouble and I was a kid I got
arrested a thousand times in and out of
rehab five times by the time I turned 16
been in mental hospitals I've been
through a lot and I rolled with a crew
of other kids that had been through a
lot other white kids that you know those
white kids right I see a couple of you
here right now you know the white kids
that get on the bus and like I'll
these white kids are here you
don't have talking about like week okay
I put it into context we were in a gang
called the PA G the pure adrenaline
gangstas what's up y'all
you guys confuse I get that I know how I
look physically now I know that my look
belies the gangster I once was I know
that I look like the only gang I've ever
belonged to as the 1920s gay French
naval submarine gang but at that time I
was thuggin right so I got to deaf
parents I'm a thug wreck super
gangster Oakland California that is the
context from which we will spring this
story I'm in so much trouble I've been
arrested so many times that my mother
tells me if you get busted one more time
you are going away for a long time I'm
sending you to a group home and that's
going to be that that's curtains for you
you're going to get sent away for a long
time and then they were like also we're
leaving town this weekend which feels
like mixed messages to me what am I
supposed to do they're leaving the house
to me and the other pure adrenaline
gangsters what do I do I invite all the
gangsters over I'm like let's have a
party mushrooms let's do some mushrooms
does Ari Shaffir is crowd like mushrooms
how about 14 year olds doing mushrooms
how do 14 year olds do mushrooms of
course we do the logical thing we go to
the liquor store we buy some Chile
picante flavored corn nuts to break the
mushrooms up into so that we can mask
the taste it's very classy experience
there's no better way to start a
psychedelic trip than with Chile picante
flavored corn nuts that's how the
ancient Mayans used to do it so we do
we're downing handfuls of Chile picante
flavored psychedelia and then somebody
else busts out he's my friend David's
like you know I got some ritalin because
it was 91 everybody had a Dede everybody
was on Ritalin and Ritalin his speed
which is awesome so we crush up the
ritalin real quick we're snorting
ritalin and eating mushrooms and then we
decide you know what let's just steal
the car let's steal the car and I'm like
this is a great idea my parents had this
1970 / 1971 bug it was not two cars it
was one car that had been sort of
Frankensteinian Lee slapped together to
create a horrible eyesore of
unparalleled proportions it had no floor
board so you could start it kind of
Flintstone style it had a button in the
back that was the ignition for some
reason it was so ugly I guess my parents
that they're assuming that it would be
too ugly for me to dare to enter but
little did they know the mushrooms I
would be eating would make that car look
exactly like a transformer and being a
14 year old boy I loved transformer so
we did that we all jumped in the car I
press the button and we drive off for 14
no licenses who cares gangsta so we
drive to this one liquor store in town
where that will sell kids our age
alcohol and we go in and we buy a bunch
of 40s all of us you know the mushrooms
are starting to kick in the ritalin is
speeding me up you know speed and
mushrooms to make the cartoons play
faster right so we go into the liquor
store we buy a bunch of 40s st. IDEs
purely I don't with Mickey's as
white boy alcohol I ain't about that
life
all right so we get all the 40s we jump
back in the car we drive to the weed
spot we buy a 20 bag and we we jump back
in the car and we drive up into the
hills of Oakland to this place called
Tilden Park it's like a wilderness
reserve in the hills of Oakland people
don't know this about Oakland we have
like redwood trees we have forests in
Oakland they forests but they gangsta at
the same time right so we're driving
through the foggy night up until dim
Park and we're looking for a spot you
know what I mean we're looking for a
spot you remember you ever do that like
you got some weed you want to smoke it
you got to find that spot we got to find
a spot chill out you know Park at the
spot look out over the over the city
we're going to get to our spot we're
going to darkness in the spot we'll pull
over we'll suck each other's dicks real
quick at the spot so we're driving
looking for the spot and we pull up onto
this earthen hill for some reason to
turn maybe the spots up here the car
literally starts to tip over backwards
we all jump out of the car like this in
sane sort of Chinese fire drill trying
to coax the car back in onto the ground
let me explain who's in the car there's
so many people in the car there is a me
and then there is my friend Joey and
then there's my friend David and there's
my friend Donny and then sitting in the
back seat of the car is my friend in
quotation marks Carlos now Carlos was so
impressive that we had him in our
Friendship Circle Carlos was a huge
gangbanger from East Oakland he was from
x3 the world's most dangerous gang
three hanging out with us the world's
least dangerous gang Carlos was a
gangbanger and we loved having him
around cuz he legitimized us you know
what I mean he was all in blue and oh
like every time you'd be like oh la we'd
be like us thank you or whatever we
loved it so much so we're willing to
ignore the fact that Carlos was
ridiculously addicted to methamphetamine
and very mentally ill so that's the
squad we got in the car that night we
got the squad and Carlos is in the back
or all we the car almost chips over
backwards we say you know what we're a
little scared let's forget about the
spot we're a little high right now I
feel like God is touching me let's not
look for the spot let's pull over right
where we are and smoke the weed right
here so I do I pick up my pipe and I
light I like to like flick the lighter I
can see the flame pop out and then all
of a sudden the lighter becomes more
light than I could have anticipated
there's light in front of me there's
light behind me I'm fully illuminated by
light and I'm like these mushrooms are
awesome
nope the cops are behind me for sure the
cops are behind me I'm in a floodlight
this doesn't make sense I'm like oh no
if I get busted one more time I'm going
away forever what do I do I gotta get
rid of the evidence so I'm in a
spotlight but I figure this will do the
trick I roll down the window put my hand
out the window drop the weed in full
illumination that takes care of that I
hear a door shut behind me I hear cop
footprints get up and then this cop
who's doing the closest thing to a joke
a police officer can do leans down picks
up the pipe hands it back to me and says
here you are I think you dropped this
and I'm like whoa what is this he's like
oh you mean the weed pipe that I just
saw you smoking from and also throwing
on the ground in the spotlight is that
what you're asking me about you want to
maybe tell me what you kids are doing
out here and I'm trying to think of a
story and I'm on speed so I'm in good
shape for a story right I'm like okay
officer here's the thing I am a bit of a
mechanic I'm a teenager mechanic kind of
a prodigy
anyway I put together these two cars
he's to the 1970 and 1971 bug had a two
disparate cars does Emily floorboards
right now but it's really it's really in
good shape anyway I got an ignition
button which is really awesome I just
thought you know just like a boat needs
a maiden voyage so to do the car so we
all show up to the car we've heard a
little drive we almost tipped over but
anyway well I think it's time for me to
go home though another see you here so I
want to thank you for pulling this over
we're gonna get going right now I'm
thinking I am doing great right now
when behind me Carlos the gangster the
thuggish of the thugs leans forward
looks at the cop but goes ah he's lying
to you officer yeah he just stole his
parents we're like what the
Carlos you were supposed to be gangster
even the cop is looking at Carlos like
dude snitches get stitches
so he says why don't you tell me what's
really going on
I say well officer oh god damn it I'm
sorry sorry about the swearing um
I swear a lot because my mom can't hear
me yeah that's right my parents are both
deaf both of them death it's hard having
deaf parents I'll tell you what but uh
hmm I get into a lot of trouble and I'm
in a lot of trouble right now and my mom
said if I get busted one more time I'm
going to a group home but you know what
it's up to you it's your call officer
you can bust me right now I can I can
get sent off to a group home slip into
the cracks in the system slip into crack
catch aids and die or you could let me
call my sister she could come out here
pick up the car take it home if you let
me call my sister it's up to you and the
cop goes okay let's call your sister
this is amazing man this is incredible
I'm gonna get out I just got to call my
sister I do not have a sister
bit of an issue I've got a half-sister
she's eight years old and lives in
Brooklyn at the time so I don't think
she can make the trip but I'm not going
to let that kind of detail stop me I say
great officer tell me what to do he says
start the car follow me down the road
and we'll get to a payphone papal intro
technology that existed back then and
we'll call your sister until we start
the car up and we start to drive let me
put this in context for everyone a
licensed officer of the law allowed a
car full of drunk high unlicensed
children in a stolen vehicle to follow
him down a foggy road in the middle of
the night how much did this guy hate
paperwork so I follow him down I get out
of the car I see the pay phone and I'm
like I don't know what to do but um God
if you're out there maybe twice in one
night isn't too much to hope for
pick up the phone and put a quarter in I
call a number of this local girl that I
know this justice chick from around the
way and I can hear it ringing ring ring
click a sleepy voice an angel like
Sister Sister Sister Sister oh the girl
with whom I share parents it is I your
brother anyway listen I need you to come
I'm in a little bit of a situation right
now I need you to come pick up the car
and take the car home pick the car up
take the car home do you understand I
can hear the gears turning in her mind
and she goes is there a cop
there right now are you calling me to
get out of trouble I'm like totally says
she's like you better get me
high if I come out there I'm like I
would like nothing better right on
officer she says she's coming she says
she's coming I turn to the guys in the
car behind I'm like she's coming the
guys like yeah
like we won the lottery 20
minutes later this girl pulls up in her
boyfriend's car she gets out she walks
right up to the officer she says oh I'm
so sorry about this officer I was fast
asleep and I didn't even hear the boys
take the car out the boys she's just
like riffing at this point she should
have won an Academy Award for such a
performance the cops like no problem and
he looks at her little inquisitively
looks at me looks at her
blond hair blue eyes Hitler's wet dream
looks back at little Jewish me like I'm
deaf parents because you know you guys
look exactly alike
was that sarcasm who was this cop I got
away man I got away sometimes you know
there's only one set of footprints in
the sand that's when God carries you you
know I got that magical luck of a drug
addict but drug addict luck always runs
out in a year after that I was back in
rehab back in a mental hospital and in
much more trouble than I'd ever been
before and if you want to know more
please check out my book kasher in the
Rye available now thank you guys so much
appreciate it
you